hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control PE dot
l2-3.10.1 limit physical access to
organizational systems equipment and the
respective operating environments to
authorized individuals
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
is feeling overwhelmed tired and alone
trying to understand all this cmmc dfars
and nist SP 10171 compliance stuff on
top of an already colossal workload well
I've got green news for you you found
your home here at on-call compliance
Solutions where we can help you
transform into your company's on-call
compliance Hero Let's jump into it all
right so here's the classic example here
you're doing you're doing a walk through
there's a network closet with a couple
of core switches in it the assessor
innocently brushes by the network cage
and the door swings open oh big problem
yes you must secure network equipment
away from non-authorized users so a few
examples locked Network closets racks
server rooms Etc you can't just let
anybody have access to the network
infrastructure okay that's a control
it's a requirement what about the
network ports themselves well you don't
have to physically lock them down but I
do think you'll find that it is much
more secure when you have real Port
control and can stop someone from
entering the area and just plug in a
device for sure they should not be able
to get on the network Itself by just
having physical access to the port and
again all these things are under
consideration here again there is
another control uh in nist sp800 171
that talks about having Port control so
I won't dive into that here but I will
make mention of it uh let's dive into
detail with what the assessors are
looking for on this one so four things
you're looking for number one determine
if authorized individuals allowed
physical access are identified so do we
know who actually is supposed to have
access to where the infrastructure is uh
this is you know if I was going to give
a sample answer I'd say Hey look it's
implemented via access control system
okay the fob or even physical keys right
that's probably maybe more of a reality
is it's a physical key on the server
room and keypad Access Control within
the physical premise security system so
lots of different options there we kind
of just throw you a big Smorgasbord of
different ways we can do access control
second assessment Point determine if
physical access to organizational
systems is limited to authorized
individuals in other words can just
anybody walk in there or is it just
limited to those people who should be
this is implemented physical access is
restricted via the physical premise
security system okay pretty
straightforward and simple and physical
access uh the physical security system
is going to lock anybody out of those
areas that they don't have access
control into again you can give a
demonstration to an assessor there
determine if physical access to
equipment is limited to authorized
individuals again sounds the same but
now we're talking about access to
equipment versus organizational systems
okay so physical access the equipment
again same answer though implemented
physical access is restricted via the
physical premise security system again
all of those things are typically going
to be in some kind of a locked room or
at least an access control room or
something like that even in small
businesses uh final assessment Point
determine a physical access to operating
environments is limited to authorized
individuals now if this these assessment
points really start to sound redundant
to you it's because they're really close
to each other point one is determined if
authorized individuals are allowed
physical access are identified do we
know who they are then the fourth one is
determinative physical access to
operating environments is limited to
authorized individuals that's the
environment you're actually operating in
okay they could be the same that could
be different keep in mind Network
infrastructure may be in one place where
your operating could be another so
implemented physical access to uh is
restricted via the physical private
security system here's a great example
if you're working with a cui related
project you may not want everybody in
your entire company in there okay you
may have to restrict access if only
those users who have been trained on cui
handling uh and again this is the
control that sort of checks for that now
uh if you're struggling with this stuff
or you're just really not sure how to
implement it in your own company the
good news is at on-call we work with
defense contractors just like like you
who have had this defars nist itar and
cmmc compliance stuff dropped into their
laps like a seagull on a sunny day and
we teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company limiting gaps gray areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance is your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that's
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you if you're looking for
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you visit cmmc compliance
secrets.com or check out the bio below
for links where you can get help right
now if you love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash that subscribe
button because that's the way to get the
latest compliance content as soon as we
put it out until the next compliance tip
my friends stay safe and secure out
there and hit us in the comments below
to let us know what you'd like to know
more about when it comes to information
security and compliance and I'll see you
on the next one
[Music]
thank you